So to recap, we've learned what is UX and
we've come up with some really good examples of user
experience. And we've learned about the difference between UI and
UX. And also we've learned that UX is everyone's responsibility.
So now, as promised, we're going to give you
two concrete examples of how you can improve user experience
of your app today. So the first one is login.
So let's look at this login or account creation form.
So, an account creation form is usually the first
thing your user sees right after they download your application.
So take a minute and think about some things
you might do to improve the UX of this form.